t c'est devenu leur habitude le matin la
balade avec les chèvres lussier tinal
son dégoût feu
elles donnent de leur temps pour
travailler à la ferme et en échange
elles sont nourries et logées à mons en
allemagne alors au volant
voire plus de 2 la france est 30 plus
français parce qu'il nous ne parlerons
pas de penser très bien apprendre la
langue française mais aussi les
rudiments de l'agriculture biologique
avec anne qui les accueillent pendant
dix jours dans sa ferme pour faire
découvrir son activité elle s'est lancé
il y a dix ans dans l'aventuré pourrait
mal au bowling c'est avant tout une
expérience de grâce ils essayent sur
erin voilà bravo super j'ai trouvé que
c'était une façon de voyager aussi et
voilà et d'accueillir j'aime beaucoup
recevoir de la traite des chèvres à la
préparation et la vente du fromage lucie
et tina sont en immersion totale
une manière pour elle de passer des
vacances utiles je veux vivre avec le
père sont français et un parce que je
pense que c'est en paille très joli et
j'aime bien la langue tant que très
difficile après leur séjour dans cette
ferme elle compte rester encore six mois
en france et renouveler l'expérience
auprès d'autres agriculteurs